why would the act of sacrifice like so
Jesus he's basically sacrificing himself
he agrees to do this why does that save
people if you look at the Old Testament
too there was always a sacrifice of a
perfect animal and then they would be
used as a mediator between God because
of the pureness of the animal you need
Perfection of that story right and so if
you aren't perfect the way you become
rightly related to God is through the
sacrifice of someone that is perfect so
Jesus becomes that unblemished lamb that
perfect sacrifice for us because his
life is perfect and so it's his imputed
righteousness that we get from believing